bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
Paris-Saclay le mag fait sa rentrée tout
comme lensa Partech l'une des 10 grandes
écoles du plateau Paris-Saclay quels
sont les nouveautés pour 2015 nous avons
posé la question à Isabelle crépon c'est
la directrice de l'établissement
accueillir de plus en plus d'étudiants
leurs professeurs des chercheurs c'est
l'un des nombreux défis à relever le
paysage se transforme les services se
développent comme L'Express 91 06 nous
ferons le point sur les dernières
avancées enfin gros plan sur Sanofi le
groupe pharmaceutique français a choisi
par Isa clé pour installer son centre de
recherche et de développement nous
verrons pourquoi et n'oublions pas notre
bloc-notes pour tout savoir sur
l'actualité de Paris Saclay
c'est la rentrée pour les étudiants de
l'insta ParisTech trois ans déjà que
cette grande école d'ingénieur est basée
sur le site Paris Saclay aujourd'hui
l'accent est mis sur l'international et
les liens avec les entreprises présentes
sur le territoire se développe nous
avons rencontré Elisabeth crépon c'est
la directrice de l'établissement
c'est la troisième rentrée de l'insta
paritex sur le plateau de Saclay je
pense qu'on peut dire qu'on est
maintenant pleinement installé sur le
sur ce plateau nous y avons trouvé nos
marques donc nous le corps enseignant
les personnels de leinsta les étudiants
vous mettrons cette année l'accent sur
l'international avec une offre à
l'international renforcée rénovée il est
très important pour nous que nos élèves
complètent leur formation à l'école par
des séjours diplômants ou non diplômants
dans des universités partenaires c'est
un élément extrêmement important pour
leur formation puis un autre point sur
lequel nous allons travailler et
proposer des nouveautés à nos élèves
c'est l'innovation puisque nous
proposons aux élèves de 3e année de
conclure leur formation par avec un
accent particulier sur la dynamique
d'innovation et d'entrepreneuriat et là
nous avons rénové les enseignements et
donc les élèves de troisième année vont
inaugurer pour la première fois ces
nouveaux enseignements
une nouveauté également pour ce qui
concerne notre lien avec les entreprises
puisque notre laboratoire de mécanique
vient de s'associer au CNRS AEDF et au
CE1 donc le CEA est un des partenaires
de l'université Paris-Saclay EDF vient
de s'installer en train de s'installer
sur le campus de Saclay les travaux sont
en cours et l'ouverture est prévue en
2015 et donc là encore c'est un élément
qui souligne notre proximité avec nos
partenaires académiques de l'université
Paris-Saclay mais également avec des
entreprises qui s'installent sur le
plateau
nous avons participé à l'ensemble des
travaux de construction d'universités
Paris Saclay ce qui concerne notamment
la construction de l'offre de formation
et la structuration de la recherche donc
proposée par l'université Paris-Saclay
ça y est c'est fait donc nous avons
travaillé sur les statuts de la nouvelle
université ces statuts ont été approuvés
par le Conseil d'Administration de
leinsta ParisTech et donc nous attendons
la création officielle de cette
université qui devrait intervenir là
tout prochainement à l'automne c'est
remarque vraiment en fait notre
attachement à ce projet et notre
investissement l'investissement des
personnels des enseignants chercheurs et
des élèves de l'école dans la réussite
de ce projet magnifique projet
accueillir des étudiants venus du monde
entier leur proposer un campus agréable
à vivre c'est l'un des nombreux défis à
relever ils seront bientôt 60000 au sein
de l'université Paris-Saclay il faut
composer avec les bâtiments présents en
construire de nouveau préserver
l'environnement une politique ambitieuse
d'aménagement du territoire et mené
regardez
c'est une opération qui couvre un
territoire très très grand qui
représente plus de 7700 hectares et qui
s'étend sur une quinzaine de kilomètres
de Versailles jusqu'à Massy jusqu'à
Palaiseau et après avec à l'intérieur
des espaces de développement dans lequel
on va aménager des différents quartiers
en effet il y a des des ensembles
considérables comme le CEA qui sont là
depuis des dizaines d'années donc il
s'agit d'une transformation et pas d'une
création Excel
et ça c'est très important c'est qu'on
s'accroche à un contexte à des présences
à des pré-existence à des usages et à
des habitants
il y a une culture paysagère très forte
on est tout proche de Versailles on est
dans un près de la vallée de Chevreuse
il y a une présence de la géographie
naturelle mais aussi de l'histoire les
boisement mais également l'eau sont des
éléments très déterminants techniquement
mais aussi dans l'ambiance que l'on
cherche à donner dans ce corpus
on retrouvera aussi des une
programmation où on va avoir bien sûr
des logements de la vraie ville comme
j'allais dire avec des commerces des
écoles mais quand même une dimension
d'éducation d'enseignement supérieur
très forte des bureaux qui sont pas des
bureaux banalisés mais des locaux de
recherche de pour des start-ups donc on
a une programmation très particulière
avec cette dimension du coût d'un public
jeune étrangers des gens qui vont de
manière temporaire qui vont habiter là
quelques mois quelques années
c'est un ensemble qui se tisse et qui
donne la structure qui permet s'orienter
facilement et donner de la qualité au
transport quand on se déplace ça doit
être agréable on doit se trouver dans un
paysage intéressant
on a ce rêve que l'arrivée à sa clé sur
le plateau justement on sera dans un
paysage et que ce campus apparaîtra
comme une sorte de très grand parc c'est
une des ambitions
rapidement ce sera bientôt chose faite
grâce à L'Express 91 06 ce bus
bénéficiera d'une voie réservée voilà
qui devrait éviter les aléas de la
circulation le prolongement de son
trajet est en cours il passera bientôt
sur ce pont que vous voyez juste
derrière moi tout de suite les
précisions d'Elisabeth Mallet c'est la
chef de projet
l'origine du projet L'Express 910 c'est
la liaison entre
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et Massy
aujourd'hui c'est la construction du
troisième maillon la première liaison a
été réalisée entre Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines et Magny-les-Hameaux la
deuxième a été réalisée entre Massy et
l'École polytechnique après les eaux
aujourd'hui il s'agit de réaliser le
site propre entre le Christ de Saclay et
l'École polytechnique à Palaiseau
assez propre c'est une infrastructure
complète donc une voix qui est dédiée
pour les bus accompagné d'une piste
cyclable et de piste pour les piétons
donc pour permettre la continuité des
modes actifs et de leur déplacement en
toute sécurité
les avantages pour L'Express 91 06 par
rapport au circuit aujourd'hui utilisé
c'est que cette infrastructure permettra
de traverser les carrefours avec une
priorité au feu donner au bus afin de
gagner en ponctualité et en régularité
le projet a été réalisé en concertation
très étroite avec les acteurs locaux
avec la CAPS avec l'établissement public
Paris Saclay pour permettre d'affiner
les choix et de retenir le parcours qui
se pourra desservir au mieux les futurs
établissements
aujourd'hui les travaux que nous venons
de voir ont débuté en novembre 2013 et
doivent s'achever fin d'année prochaine
donc fin 2015 pour la mise en service
ce projet a un coût total de 58,2
millions d'euros hors taxes en valeur
2008 il est entièrement financé par
l'État la région et le département de
l'Essonne le matériel roulant et
l'exploitation sont eux 100% financés
par le STIF
on vous emmène maintenant à
Chilly-Mazarin Longjumeau siège social
et mondial de la recherche et du
développement en pharmacie à campus
fortement connecté au Centre de
recherche du plus grand groupe
pharmaceutique français Sanofi Sanofi
qui a choisi Paris sa clé pourquoi
élément de réponse avec ce sujet
ici nous sommes dans un site de
recherche et développement de
l'industrie pharmaceutique l'objectif
des scientifiques et des médecins du
site et de trouver de nouveaux
médicaments pour les patients
1800 personnes travaillent sur toutes
les étapes de recherche et de
développement des médicaments ce qui
fait que le site de shimmazarin est l'un
des plus importants au niveau mondial
pour Sanofi
nous travaillons sur la recherche
fondamentale la recherche qui est proche
du monde académique la recherche pour
les médicaments dans le domaine
cardiovasculaire dans le domaine des
maladies neurodégénératives Alzheimer
Parkinson et puis après la recherche
nous organisons sur le site la
coordination sur les études de clinique
les études de cliniques ça consiste à
pouvoir démontrer après au niveau
mondial chez les patients que nos
médicaments vont être efficaces avec un
minimum de risque pour les malades
ce qui est très important pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique pour la santé
des patients c'est de pouvoir suivre
l'efficacité et la sécurité des
médicaments ensuite quand ils sont sur
le marché c'est la pharmacovigilance et
de l'argile de pharmacovigilance
travaille sur le site
donc nous sommes sur toute la chaîne de
la recherche au développement au
bénéfice des patients dans le monde
pour nous pour les équipes de
scientifiques et de médecins du site il
est dès essentiel de pouvoir être
connecté avec les meilleurs équipes au
niveau académique c'est ce que nous
trouvons et ce que nous allons trouver
avec les équipes de Paris sacs
nous avons des puzzlocks des étudiants
qui après leur thèse viennent débuter
leur activité dans le domaine de la
recherche en industrie et également nous
avons une pratique de pouvoir accueillir
des équipes universitaires par exemple
de Paris-Sud ou bien de l'Université de
Versailles
le centre de recherche existe depuis
1958 et les équipes dont je viens de
parler ont noué des collaborations avec
des équipes du plateau de Saclay mirsen
NeuroSpin le Labex l'ermite le CEA
autant de centres d'excellence qui vont
nous permettre de mieux rechercher et
développer nos médicaments
avant de nous quitter votre bloc-notes
tout ce qui s'est passé ou qui va se
passer à Paris Saclay avec déjà le coup
d'envoi du lieu de vie dans le quartier
du Moulon ce futur espace de rencontrer
de partage accueillera une cafétéria
versions XXL avec 1000 couverts mais
aussi des activités sportives les
travaux ont commencé même chose pour
l'ismo l'Institut des Sciences
moléculaires d'Orsay ce nouveau bâtiment
de haute technologie abritera 170
personnes rentrez chargée pour le proto
204 avec 3 workshops pour mieux
identifier vos besoins en service
numérique le proto 204 qui vous a aussi
proposé une journée design des
professionnels du secteur sont venus
rappeler l'intérêt du design dans le
secteur des hautes technologies le
design c'est bien les mathématiques
aussi mathématiques et entrepreneuriat
ce thème surprenant a accueilli plus de
250 participants au premier forum d'un
cube alliance mais pour tout savoir sur
les projets de Paris-Saclay et leurs
avancements je vous invite à aller à
l'exposition qui se tiendra du 27
novembre au 15 décembre à la Maison de
l'Architecture un événement à ne pas
rater
et voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve le mois prochain
pour un nouveau numéro de Paris Saclay
le bang